لا تزال مساعدات الاداره الذاتيه والاهالي
لمنكوبي زلزال في مناطق المعارضه ونظام
علقه هنا في المعابر هذه القافله تضم 30
صهريجا محمله بالوقود وهي الماده الاكثر
طلبا في عموم سوريا تجمدت هنا منذ ايام
تقول الاداره الذاتيه انها لا تضع اي شروط
لادخالها سوى سلامه السائقين والقافله
ذهبا وايابا بينما الحكومه المؤقته في
شمال غرب البلاد اشارت في بيان لها انها
تقبل مساعدات الاهالي والمنظمات بما معنى
انها ترفض مساعدات الاداره وقصد ليس ببعيد
من هنا علقت 100 شاحنه في معبر التايهه
تحمل الوقود والمواد الاغاثيه والانسانيه
كمساعدات لمناطق النظام يقول الاكراد ان
دمشق تطالب بحصه 80% منها كشرط لادخالها
وفيما يستمر الف في تسييس المساعدات
وعرقلتها تزداد معاناه السوريين الذين
وحدهم الزلزال من معبر ام جلود في مدينه
منبج شمال شرق سوريا جماعه كاش للعربيه
والحدث